Am Freitag findet die WM-Auslosung zum Turnier im Sommer statt. Doch wie laufen in Russland eigentlich die Vorbereitungen darauf? Darüber spreche ich mit der Bloggerin Katrin Scheib jetzt hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Katrin, Grüße nach Moskau. Heißt das jetzt Guten Morgen oder einfach nur Servus?
Das heißt so Hallo.
Ach ja, die Sprachbarriere, das ist ja schon mal eins der Themen. Über das wir dann auch gleich sprechen können. Es freut mich sehr, dass wir zwei zusammengefunden haben. Du machst einen sehr interessanten Newsletter rund um die Vorbereitungen auf die Weltmeisterschaft in Russland. Der läuft auch schon ein paar Ausgaben. Den machst du immer wöchentlich. Und so habe ich dich gefunden. Deshalb die einfache Frage. Wie ist denn die Situation gerade in Russland? Freut sich das Land auf die WM?
Also ich glaube, das Land ist ein bisschen breit gefasst, weil es dafür einfach noch zu lange hin ist. Ich meine, es fängt im Juni an. Es sind noch über sechs Monate. Ich glaube, die Leute, die sich für Fußball interessieren, da merkt man so langsam die Vorfreude. Es laufen gerade die Schulungen für die Freiwilligen. Es tourt der Pokal durchs Land, also durch die Austragungsorte, wird also von einer Gastgeberstadt an die nächste weitergereicht. Jetzt klar, mit der Auslosung am Freitag, da wächst natürlich das Interesse. Aber es ist jetzt noch nicht so Sommermärchen-Gefühl. Das war es in Deutschland natürlich sechs, sieben Monate vorher auch noch nicht.
Das war es auch drei Tage vorher auch noch nicht. Es war kalt, aber es ist 2006.
Kalt haben wir hier im Moment auch.
Ja gut, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Erster Schnee hast du mir im Vorgespräch erzählt. Wie ist denn der Stand der Vorbereitungen auf die WM? Wie sieht es denn zum Beispiel im Punkt 2 Stadien aus?
Ja, das variiert. Also es gibt ja die vier Stadien, Moskau, Petersburg, Kasan und Sochi, die schon bei der Proberunde jetzt im Sommer, beim Konfett Cup in Gebrauch waren. Also in Moskau wird es ja zwei Stadien geben bei der WM. Eins davon haben sie bei dem Konfett Cup schon bespielt. Das hat alles gut geklappt. Da haben sie quasi eine große Generalprobe gehabt. Da kannst du davon ausgehen, dass das funktioniert. Bei den anderen ist es unterschiedlich. Also es gab jetzt letzte Woche ein Statement, wo es noch mal darum ging, ob wir auf Stand sind. Da haben die Organisatoren schon gesagt, dass sie bei einigen Projekten hängen. Ich glaube, am meisten betroffen ist Samara. Aber das ist hier so ein wichtiges, prestigeträchtiges Projekt. Ich habe keine Zweifel, dass das jetzt irgendwie durchgepeitscht wird und dass mit Anpfiff da die Stadien fertig sind. Vielleicht drei Tage vorher noch nicht und vielleicht nicht in einer Bauweise, die dafür sorgt, dass alles dann auch für die Ewigkeit hält. Aber das ist das Klassische Just-in-Time.
Wenn wir schon was über Stadien gehört haben, hier in Deutschland, von der WM in Russland, dann ging es vor allem um das eine Stadion, bei dem die Tribüne ausgelagert wurde. Das sieht sehr merkwürdig aus. Kannst du mir noch mal kurz erklären, wie es dazu kam?
Ja, das ist das Stadion in Yekaterinburg und da war nicht genug Platz drin. Das klassische Think Outside the Box war dann offenbar Think Outside the Stadium. Da haben sie quasi an einer Seite einen Durchbruch gemacht. Da ist jetzt eine Tribüne, die aus dem Stadion raus ragt. Das heißt, du sitzt außerhalb des Stadions, guckst aber rein. Da gibt es natürlich sehr unterschiedliche Prognosen. Leute, die sagen, ich werde da nichts sehen. Leute, die sagen, es ist spektakulär und man fühlt sich wie ein Vogel und was weiß ich. Da kannst du nur abwarten, wie dann die Berichte der Fans sind, wenn dann da wirklich mal Spiele veranstaltet werden.
Jetzt gab es ja eine WM-Bewerbung. Ich vermute mal, da stand aber nicht drin, dass man die Tribüne so aus dem Stadion einfach rauslöst, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht. Also wie detailliert das in der Bewerbung beschrieben war? Kann ich dir jetzt für einzelne Stadien nicht sagen. Aber es ist natürlich so, die Vorgaben, also ungefähr in welchen Dimensionen man da Fans platzieren kann, die sind natürlich festgeschrieben. Und genau darum musste das gelöst werden.
Na ja, eine interessante Variante. Aber wir erinnern uns, bei der WM in Brasilien gab es ja auch die eine Tribüne, die noch gar nicht überdacht war, glaube ich. Das sah auch etwas spektakulär aus, um es euphemistisch zu sagen. Das heißt, du hast keinerlei Bedenken, dass die Stadien und alles fertig werden. Wie sieht es denn rund um die Infrastruktur aus? Da kommt ja dann die Sprachbarriere auch wirklich mit dazu. Glaubst du, das kann ein Problem werden, wenn man dann viele, nicht des russischen und des kyrillischen, mächtigen Fans im Land hat, und die muss man dann irgendwie Richtung Fußballstadion bewegen?
Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Gerade außerhalb dieser vier Städte, die ich jetzt schon erwähnt habe, also in Moskau und Petersburg musst du dir keine Gedanken machen. Das sind solche Beliebtziele bei internationalen Touristen, egal ob da eine WM stattfindet oder nicht. Die haben jahrelange Erfahrung damit. Also gerade in Moskau hast du in den letzten Jahren auch noch mal gemerkt, wie sehr die im Vorfeld der WM Gas geben. Also, weiß ich nicht, ein Freund, der vor eineinhalb Jahren hier war und dann vor einem Jahr noch mal kam, dann sagte er, warte mal, da sind plötzlich lauter englische Durchsagen in der Metro. Also nicht nur auf der einen Linie, wo sie es länger schon probiert haben, sondern eben auf allen Linien oder Straßenschilder auf Englisch und auf Russisch. Und dann eben halt dadurch, dass sie Englisch sind, auch in lateinischer Schrift. Wenn du dich außerhalb der großen Metropolen bewegst, nicht, dass die anderen Austragsorte nicht auch Großstädte wären, aber eben vielleicht nicht immer die klassischen Touristenmagnete, dann kann das schon ganz anders aussehen. Auch zum Beispiel, was jetzt die Englischkenntnisse in der Bevölkerung angeht. Also hier in Moskau, klar, da ist mal jemand unwirsch und geht weiter oder kann kein Englisch, aber wenn du irgendwie dann den zweiten und dritten Menschen fragst und vielleicht tendenziell jemand Jüngeres, vielleicht auch tendenziell eine Frau, der das Ego nicht so im Weg steht mit Verlaub, bei drücke ich mich jetzt akkurat aus oder nicht, dann findest du schon, wen der dir hilft. Aber zum Beispiel in Sochi, beim Confed Cup, ich war da spontan und am Abend hat Deutschland gespielt, ich wollte mir eine Karte kaufen fürs Spiel und hatte Zeit den Tag über, hatte nichts vor und dann habe ich gedacht, jetzt probierst du das mal nur auf Englisch, als ob du kein Russisch könntest. Und das war schon ein fortgeschrittener Angang. Ich glaube, das hat zwei Stunden gedauert, bis ich endlich da stand, wo man die dann kaufen konnte. Also ich wollte die nicht im Netz kaufen, sondern im echten Leben. Und dann rausfinden, wo ist das Gebäude und wer kann mir sagen, wo ich hin muss. Die Leute waren sehr freundlich und wenn sie was auf Russisch gesagt haben, was ich dann verstanden habe, war das auch schon hilfsbereit. Aber es war kaum einer in der Lage, es auf Englisch mal zu erklären. Darauf sollte man sich einstellen, klar. Es ist aber ja generell so, ich meine, du gehst auf Reisen. Wenn du schlau bist, schaffst du dir vorher ein bisschen was an der Landessprache drauf. Und wenn es nur das übliche Ja-Nein-Bitte-Danke-Guten-Tag-Ein-Bier ist.
Ja, gut. Und wenn man auch jetzt schon anfängt, die Freiwilligen auszubilden, dann wird ja auch das wahrscheinlich eins der Hauptthemen sein. Wie könnt ihr euch verständigen mit den Fans, die da kommen? Gibt es denn irgendwelche Zweifel, dass die Stadien, wir sprechen davon Kapazitäten von so 35.000 bis hin zu 81.000, dann im Luzhniki-Stadion in Moskau, gibt es Zweifel, dass die Stadien voll besetzt sein werden?
Naja, also mit Blick auf den Konfett-Cup kann man durchaus Zweifel kriegen. Das ist die eine Seite. Da war das gerade an den ersten Spieltagen so, da war schon viel frei. Und dann später, klar, wurden viele Karten verschenkt an Schulklassen, an Sportclubs. Da sitzt du dann irgendwie im Stadion, neben dir sitzen da so Leute und rufen Kamerun, Kamerun! Und die haben garantiert gesehen, es gibt zum ersten Mal ein Spiel von Kamerun. Aber die sind jetzt eben als Kamerun-Anfeuerer da. Und das natürlich besser verschenken als leere Ränge, auf jeden Fall. Andererseits, als ich meine, wen interessiert der Confed Cup? Wen hat der Confed Cup vor irgendeiner anderen WM mal interessiert? Das ist natürlich eine komplett andere Dimension, wenn hier eine WM kommt. Bis jetzt sehen die Zahlen für die Ticket-Vorkäufe, glaube ich, ganz gut aus. Und jetzt, wenn Freitag die Auslosung ist, startet ich glaube Sonntag die nächste Verkaufsrunde, wo man dann halt auch eine genauere Vorstellung hat, wo spielt denn meine Mannschaft, also was muss ich tun, um die zu sehen. Also ich glaube, dass vielleicht nicht jedes Spiel in der Gruppenphase ausverkauft sein wird, aber ich glaube nicht, dass man sich Gedanken machen muss über mangelnde Atmosphäre.
Wie sind denn die Tickets bepreist? Können sich das auch Einheimische leisten?
Da gibt es so einen Trick, oder ein Trick ist quasi eine Regelung, dass es für Leute, die hier leben, eine eigene Preisklasse gibt. Also du kannst natürlich die üblichen und durchaus teuren Summen bezahlen, es gibt aber, wenn du belegen kannst, dass du hier ortsansässig bist, gibt es eine eigene Preisklasse, die sind dann auch nicht billig, aber die passen eher zu dem, was man hier an Durchschnittseinkommen kennt. Also es ist dann immer noch nicht komm, wir gehen mal zu fünf Spielen, aber es kann sich vielleicht eher auch jemand mit einem russischen Einkommen, vielleicht eben auch nicht mit einem Einkommen aus der Hauptstadt, wo man tendenziell hier in Moskau mehr verdient als anderswo, trotzdem mal leisten, zu einem Spiel zu gehen.
Na das ist ja eine schöne Sache.
Ist ein guter Ansatz, glaube ich auch.
Was glaubst du denn, wie weit ist die Infrastruktur jetzt, vor allem wenn wir rausgehen aus St. Petersburg und Moskau, was du schon angesprochen hast. Die Stadien sind ja unglaublich weiträumig verteilt. Ich selber kann mir ehrlich gesagt noch keine Vorstellungen davon machen, wie das überhaupt wird, was für Flugstunden da auch anfallen für Teams. Das wird man jetzt auch alles erst bei der Auslosen, glaube ich, so richtig dann umreißen können, wenn man auch weiß, wer spielt eigentlich wo. Aber hast du einen Eindruck davon, wie eben zum Beispiel in Yekaterinburg, das ist der östlichste Spielort, wenn ich es richtig sehe, wie da die Infrastruktur aufgebaut ist?
Also was ich jetzt, was ich zum Beispiel sagen kann ist, also für die Teams sind das natürlich vielleicht mal lange Flüge, aber dadurch, dass eben, dass die Organisatoren nach Yekaterinburg den Strich gezogen haben, ist es auch nicht, es sind keine furchtbaren Dimensionen. Also es ist nicht zum Beispiel wie in der russischen ersten Liga, wo du dann halt auch mal von, naja, Moskau, 10, 11 Stunden fliegen musst für ein normales Spiel, und dann, also diese Dimension hat es nicht. Klar, es ist trotzdem einiges an Rumgegurke, gerade weil ja auch an den verschiedenen Standorten die Mannschaften spielen, und da soll ja zum Beispiel helfen, diese Fan-Züge, die du, wenn du eine Fan-ID hast, kostenlos benutzen kannst, musst du dich vorher anmelden, relativ früh planen. Das setzt aber einen gewissen Sportgeist voraus, wenn du dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, von sagen wir mal, Sochi nach Kazan musst oder so, also das ist schon mehr als 24 Stunden im Zug, ne? Also das muss man wollen. Ist aber halt eine Option, also gerade wenn du vielleicht etwas mehr Zeit hast als Geld, dann kannst du damit planen. Das andere sind so Sachen wie Flugtickets. Da kannst du, weiß ich nicht, alle paar Monate siehst du hier die Meldungen, wie wieder die Preise gestiegen sind. Das ist natürlich was, das nehmen Aeroflot und andere Fluglinien hier total gerne mit, weil natürlich klar ist, die Leute müssen dann eben auch von A nach B kommen. Und da ist Fliegen halt immer noch die einfachste Variante.
Also die Dimensionen des Landes Russlands, die werden einem wirklich nochmal bewusst, wenn man sich allein diesen östlichsten Spielort Jekaterinburg anguckt und dann sieht, wie weit Russland da eigentlich noch weitergeht. Das ist eigentlich nicht zu umreißen. Ich habe jetzt gerade mal versucht, im Kopf Frankreich reinzusetzen und zu messen, wie viele Frankreichs wir hier allein zwischen den jetzigen Spielorten haben. War das denn mal ein Thema in Russland, dass es östlich davon keinen Spielort gibt und dann ja auch die Städte dort nicht von der WM profitieren und irgendwie auch nicht so ganz daran teilhaben?
Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das gar nicht. Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Allerdings, also das schließt überhaupt nicht aus, dass es diese Debatte gab, ist mir allerdings nicht begegnet.
Wie ist denn das, wenn einem Debatten begegnet? Das bringt einen ja auch so ein bisschen zur Medienlandschaft. Wie muss ich mir das in Russland vorstellen? Wie divers sind da die öffentlichen Diskussionen?
Ja, also du hast hier natürlich, gerade dadurch, wie wichtig Fernsehen ist und wie sehr das in staatlicher Hand ist, hast du sehr viel sehr wohlwollende Vorberichterstattung, die sich dann eben auch oder auch zum Beispiel TAS, die staatlichen Nachrichtenagentur, die hat auf ihrer, also kann man sich eigentlich auch anschauen, das ist ganz interessant, auf deren Website haben die halt einen eigenen Bereich zur WM und zu den WM-Vorbereitungen und das ist ehrlich gesagt auf dem großen Spektrum von Journalismus zur Öffentlichkeitsarbeit teilweise deutlich näher am Letzten. Also in Stadion X wird jetzt auch der Rasen ausgesät und in Stadion Y, weiß ich auch nicht, gab es jetzt ein Futsal-Turnier, so grob dieses Prinzip, das ist schon sehr detailliert, hohe Schlagzahl, eher an guter Stimmung als jetzt an Relevanzkriterien ausgerichtet. Das heißt aber nicht, dass es keine kritische Berichterstattung gibt. Also es gibt durchaus, es gibt einiges an Zeitungen und deren Websites, wo berichtet wird, über Kosten, über Preisanstiege zum Beispiel, die zu erwarten sind, darüber, wie die Versorgung sein wird mit Wi-Fi oder, ja weiß ich nicht, jetzt hänge ich.
Wie schnell man zum Starten kommt wahrscheinlich und wie viel die öffentliche Hand zuschießen muss.
Das ist natürlich eine große Wahlstelle, klar. Aber da wird durchaus berichtet, also jetzt auch diese ganzen Sachen mit, wann war es, vor vielleicht so zwei Monaten, als die letzte Runde bekannt wurde, dass die Kosten wieder steigen. Das wird durchaus und auch kritisch berichtet.
Wird der dann vermutlich aus dem russischen Staatshaushalt finanziert, das Turnier, oder?
Ja, also das ist, glaube ich, eine einfache Rechnung für, wer ist du jetzt, russischer Staatschef? Also was das an Prestige, an internationaler Aufmerksamkeit, an Einnahmen durch Tourismus bringt, aber wie gesagt einfach auch an Standing. Das ist analog zu Sochi.
Ja, das kauft man sich quasi mit dem Turnier ein und das ist ja dann gewollt. Und ehrlich gesagt sind Kosten dann ja auch nicht das große Thema. Wie ist es denn mit anderen, etwas kritischeren Themen? Also hier aus der deutschen Perspektive wird natürlich auch viel über Doping gesprochen. Gerade im Fall Russlands haben wir da ja ein systematisches Doping, was inzwischen immer besser aufgedeckt wurde, das in der Vergangenheit liegt. Und dann ja auch das Thema Fangewalt. Lass mal mit Doping anfangen. Spielt dieses Thema in der Berichterstattung in Russland eine Rolle?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also das wird durchaus berichtet. Das ist halt dein Hin und Her, er sagt, sie sagt, die WADA sagt dies, russische Offizielle sagen das. Also es ist jetzt nicht, dass das Thema totgeschwiegen würde oder so, das findet schon alles statt. Der Tenor der Berichterstattung ist natürlich, wie gesagt, Stichpunkt Staatsmedien, Klarkommen dann, detailliert, offizielle Stellen eben zur Sprache, die sich dann äußern dürfen, dementieren auch lange und das hat natürlich, also in der Bevölkerung, das ist jetzt schon was her, ich glaube, das war im Juno oder Juli gab es eine Umfrage und da hat die Mehrheit der Russen gesagt, dass was Dvada da ermittelt hat, das glauben wir nicht, das halten wir für nicht fundiert, das ist so nicht. Das ist halt das Ergebnis von solch einer Berichterstattung.
Und kann man schon abschätzen, welche Auswirkungen das aufs Turnier selbst haben wird? Hat sich die FIFA dazu auch schon positioniert? Wie werden Doping-Kontrollen rund ums Turnier stattfinden?
Ja, da gab es doch jetzt Anfang der Woche diesen Film, wo Gianni Infantino gesagt hat, was man alles von der WM erwarten kann. Und da kamen natürlich Vorverpflichtungen, strenge Doping-Kontrollen und so alles andere jetzt zu prognostizieren, wie effektiv die sind, dass jetzt irgendwie sieben Monate vorher, das wäre Glaskugelkuckerei, aber du siehst es ja jetzt, jetzt kriegen wieder Leute, russische Athleten, Medaillen aberkannt wegen Doping in Tzotzi. Und das ist, Tzotzi ist was, drei Jahre her, fast drei Jahre her. Das heißt, wie effektiv da Kontrollen sind, wie rigide, das sehen wir beinturniert und danach.
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe auch bei dir gelesen, dass dadurch, dass die russische Anti-Doping-Agentur noch suspendiert sei, alle Doping-Proben außerhalb des Landes kontrolliert würden.
Genau, das wurde bekanntgegeben und da muss man halt schauen, wie effektiv das ist, wie gut gesichert dieser Weg ist, bei dem die halt außer Landes gebracht werden.
Das werden wir wahrscheinlich auch erst wieder im Nachhinein erfahren, so wie das immer ist bei solchen Themen.
Genau, so sagen wir mal ab Mitte Juli.
Ja, 15. Juli ist das WM-Finale. Ja, und dann das Thema Hooligans und Fangewalt. Da haben wir noch schlimme Bilder von der EM in Frankreich vor Augen, auch mit Beteiligung russischer Hooligans. Wird darüber jetzt im Vorhinein berichtet, kommt da auch so was wie die Fan-ID mit rein? Da musst du dich vorhin gleich dran denken, als du gesagt hast, also du kannst natürlich kostenlos die Züge benutzen, aber dafür musst du dich registrieren. Hängt das mit diesem Sicherheitsaspekt zusammen?
Also die Fan-ID hat natürlich mit Sicherheit zu tun, nicht nur mit Hooligans, sondern einfach auch generell, dass Russland wissen will, wer in sein Land einreist und wo er sich aufhält. Es ist ja, also zu großen Teilen ersetzt die Fan-ID ja das, was du sonst per Visum machen musst. Also du kannst da mit visumsfrei einreisen, gibst aber ehrlich gesagt genauso Daten von dir preis, wie du das sonst für ein Visum tätest. Und hinzu kommt ja auch, du musst dich ja auch hier immer registrieren, wenn du im Land bist. Also es reicht nicht einzureisen, es gibt eine Registrierungspflicht. Da musst du dich melden, wenn du in einem Hotel unterkommst, macht es dein Hotel für dich. Das machen die, wenn du quasi deinen Pass an der Rezeption abgibst. Wenn du dir was privat mietest, weiß ich nicht, Airbnb oder andere Plattformen, kann das durchaus ein bisschen komplizierter sein, weil du dich dann selber kümmern musst. Denn eigentlich muss dein Vermieter mit dir dahingehen, das tun die Allerwenigsten. Und das ist üblich, ist die Frist für eine Registrierung des sieben Arbeitstage. Während des Convert Cups haben sie das aber geändert auf einen. Das heißt, du musst dich immer sofort, das galt nur für die Austragungsorte, aber da musst du dich immer sofort bei der Polizei melden, wenn du da warst. Und das ist natürlich schon sehr engmaschig. Hinzu kommt, es gibt hier so eine offizielle Liste von Leuten, die nicht zu WM-Veranstaltungen kommen dürfen vom Innenministerium. Das sind, lass mich nicht lügen, zwischen 300 und 400 Namen sollen da drauf stehen. Ich habe jetzt die genaue Zahl nicht parat. Das sind vor allem Leute, die eben durch Gewalt aufgefallen sind. Ich habe ein, zwei Berichte gesehen, dass da auch andere bei sind, die jeweils nicht erwischt wurden, wie sie schwarz mit Tickets gehandelt haben oder so. Aber das Prinzip dieser Liste ist der Versuch, Hooligans fernzuhalten, Gewalt zu vermeiden. Das ist der eine Strang. Das andere ist dann eben alles, was mit Sicherheit, Polizei, Miliz, anderen Einheiten zu tun hat. Es gibt hier die sogenannten OMON. Das ist eine Spezialeinheit, die gehört zur Nationalgarde. Sie ist aus einer Anti-Terror-Einheit hervorgegangen. Als ich zu meinem ersten russischen Ligaspiel gegangen bin, war das schon richtig gruselig. Da sind in voller Montur Wäste, Helm, alles. Sie stehen in der Metro und haben ein Auge auf die Leute. Die ganze Inszenierung, wie die sich präsentieren, ist schon Teil des Abschreckungsprogramms. Gerade, wenn du mal ein heikles Derby hast, sind die schon sehr sichtbar. Beim Confed Cup war es eher so, du hast sehr viel reguläre Polizei gesehen an den Stadien, durchaus geschult, sehr viel mehr freundlich, lächeln, nicken, da geht es lang, Freund und Helfer. Als man das sonst hier von Ordnungskräften kennt. Das ist bestimmt eine der großen Aufgaben, die jetzt hier abgewogen werden. Wie sehr setze ich auf Abschreckung und auf demonstrative Polizeipräsenz oder sogar über Polizei? Und wie sehr kann ich nicht riskieren, mir durch so eine Drohkulisse die Stimmung zu ruinieren? Ich glaube, das ist genau das, was hier in den nächsten Monaten austariert wird.
So wie ja auch bei allen zurückliegenden Russlandspazieren. In Frankreich gesehen, auch in Brasilien, da hatten wir dann eher soziale Unruhen. Das hat ja nicht primär mit Hooliganismus zu tun. Aber dieses Thema begleitet uns jetzt leider schon ein paar Jahre. Wenn ich böswillig wäre, würde ich von außen betrachtet unterstellen, naja, ich erinnere mich an so manche Äußerungen des Sportministers bei der EM in Frankreich, der den Fans noch zugejubelt hat, nachdem man schon wusste, was im Vorfeld eines Spiels gegen England war, was passiert ist, der auch im Nachhinein gesagt hat, naja, letztlich haben sie doch nur sich als gute Patrioten gezeigt. Da würde ich jetzt die Unterstellung dann aufstellen können, naja, im eigenen Land hat man dann die eigenen Hooligans zumindest besser im Griff. Aber ist denn das überhaupt zutreffend bei Leuten, denen es nur ums Gekloppe geht? Hast du da ein Gefühl zu?
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt, bei dem, was du jetzt gerade zitierst, nicht sicher, ob das wirklich Mutko war oder nicht, lebe der vier ein Duma-Abgeordneter. Also bei dem erinnere ich mich sehr deutlich, dass der gesagt hat, super Jungs. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das der Sportminister war. Aber klar, es gibt so Stimmen und das sind dann natürlich irgendwelche populistischen Politiker, die nicht verpflichtet sind hier oder anders, die durch solche Kommentare halt wissen, in welchen Wählergruppen sie fischen können und die dann eben sagen, super Jungs, weiter so gut gemacht. Also genau das gab es ja. Ich sehe nicht, was wir daran falsch gemacht haben. Das gibt es und jetzt musst du mich noch mal erinnern, was deine eigentliche Frage war.
Damals gab es schon so Theorien, dass man gesagt hat, na die russischen Fans, diejenigen, die aus Gewalt eine Freude ziehen, die haben jetzt noch mal eine der letzten Möglichkeiten genutzt, denn im eigenen Land wird man es nicht machen und dann in Katar wird sowieso eine ganz andere Nummer sein. Das war aber halt natürlich eine Unterstellung, das kann man jetzt mit Fakten basieren.
Ja, das finde ich auch schwer abzuschätzen. Dafür gibt es ja Leute, die wirklich in der hooligen Szene recherchieren und da sehr viel besser vernetzt sind, sehr viel tiefer Bericht erstatten. Da bin ich ja auch eher Leserin, was solche Themen angeht. Was sicherlich stimmt ist, Russland ist ein autoritär regierter Staat. Polizei und andere Sicherheitskräfte sind hier, wenn es drauf ankommt, wenig zimperlich. Und das kann den Effekt haben, dass man weniger an hooligen Gewalt erlebt. Da traue ich mir keine Prognose zu.
Dann lassen wir noch zum Sportlichen kommen. Wie sieht man denn im Land die Chancen der eigenen Nationalmannschaft?
Oh, realistisch vielleicht. Na ja, nach allem, was ich weiß, ist Russland bei einer WM noch nie über die Gruppenphase hinausgekommen. Und wenn das jetzt bei der WM im eigenen Land vielleicht noch mit diesem extra Antrieb, das ja quasi ein großes Heimspiel ist, nun doch geschehe, dann werden sicherlich viele Leute sehr glücklich, aber bestimmt, wenn sie ehrlich sind, auch überrascht. Russland ist natürlich keine schlechte Mannschaft, die wird sich nicht blamieren, die kann durchaus mit manchen, die sich hier qualifiziert haben, mithalten. Aber das ist, was ich auch noch sagen wollte, genau, es waren in den letzten Spielen gerade durchaus Achtungserfolge bei, wo man auch mal Spielzüge länger gesehen hat, man hat gedacht, ach guck mal, das ist ja dann doch sehr viel zielgerichteter und auch ein bisschen schneller als man es sonst so kennt. Da können schon gute Dinge passieren. Ich glaube nicht, dass die untergehen in ihrer Gruppe. Aber du hast halt einfach so Begegnungen, weiß ich nicht, auch beim Confed Cup irgendwie im Insochi im Taxi, Gespräch mit einem Taxifahrer, der sagt, ah, Sie sind aus Deutschland, ja. Diese Deutsche gibt es ja nicht so, ja so 80 Millionen ungefähr, sagt er. Sie haben 80 Millionen und da haben sie jetzt diese Mannschaft also gefunden, genug Männer, um Weltmeister zu werden. Und wir sind was? 145 Millionen und wir finden so elf Leute nicht. Warum denn nicht? Und dann bist du halt ganz tief da drin. Wie funktioniert hier Fußball? Wie wird Jugendarbeit gemacht oder eben nicht gemacht? Wie setzt man auf eingekaufte statt eigene Talente? Wie hoch ist das, was Fußballer hier, sind die Gehälter, die Fußballer hier verdienen, wodurch es vielleicht gar nicht attraktiv wird, mal im Ausland zu spielen und da zuzulernen? Also da kannst du dann strukturell natürlich tiefe Debatten über das Warum führen.
Ja. Jetzt bist du ja als Bloggerin vor Ort in Russland. Spielt denn da die aktuelle politische Lage für die Weltmeisterschaft auch eine Rolle? Also wir nehmen auf an einem Tag, an dem ich heute Morgen ein paar Push-Notifications gelesen habe. A, Nordkorea hat angeblich eine Langstreckenraketen gezündet, die wohl um den ganzen Globus fliegen könnte und wir kennen ja alle die Russland-Verbindungen zwischen dem US-Präsidenten, dem amtierenden oder zumindest die unterstellten Verbindungen. Wie ist denn so die politische Lage im Land und wird sich das auch auf das Turnier irgendwie auswirken?
Also ich glaube, dass die beiden Themen, die du jetzt angerissen hast, Nordkorea oder USA, dass die da weniger Auswirkungen haben. Was viel wichtiger ist, ist, wir haben hier im kommenden Frühjahr Präsidentenwahlen und auch wenn er immer noch kokettiert und noch nicht gesagt hat, ob er nochmal antritt, wird also dann nach allem, was man jetzt vorher sagen kann, Putin seine nächste Amtszeit beginnen.
Also vor der WM noch sind die Präsidentenwahlen?
Ja, die sind im März. Ich nagel mich jetzt nicht fest auf den genauen Termin. Und das ist natürlich was, vor Präsidentenwahlen gibt es traditionell natürlich irgendwelche, also da ist dem Präsidenten daran gelegen, dass die Stimmung im Land gut ist, dass es hier Aufschwung gibt, dass es hier positive Grundstimmung gibt, für die er dann eben der Repräsentant sein kann und dadurch seine Wiederwahl erreichen. Und da ist so erfolgreiche WM-Vorbereitung sicherlich auch ein Teil, was dazu beiträgt. Schau mal, wir stemmen hier dieses Turnier, das ist eine große Sache, die Welt blickt auf uns und wir spielen da sowohl sportlich als auch in Sachen Relevanz auf einem gewissen Niveau mit. Das ist natürlich ein Narrativ, der da stattfindet.
Und wie ist das als Bloggerin in Russland zu leben? Also du bloggst auf Deutsch, ich würde mal damit die These aufstellen, damit fliegst du ein bisschen unter dem Radar, denn du wendest dich ja an ein deutschsprachiges Publikum. Aber ist das irgendwas anderes, als wenn ich jetzt hier in Deutschland einen Blog aufmachen würde und einfach über die WM schreiben würde?
Ja, es ist also bei Berichterstattung über solche Themen. Russball, der wochenliche Newsletter-Blogpost, das ist halt wirklich über Fußball. Ansonsten bilde ich hier meinen Alltag in Russland ab. Das sind unterschiedliche Themen. Das ist aber natürlich nicht die Recherchetiefe von politisch tiefgehendem Journalismus. Das ist es nicht, sondern das ist mein persönliches Blog. Wie du sagst, das ist abseits jeglicher Relevanz für irgendwelche staatlichen Autoritäten. Also Relevanz sind so Sachen wie AED-Doping-Berichterstattung. Relevanz sind so Sachen wie große Scoops, wer ist in welche Korruptionssachen verstrickt. Das sind Themen, die finden dann auch nicht in Blogs statt, sondern da sind einige russische Medien, einige ausländische Korrespondenten, die müssen sich Gedanken darüber machen, wer guckt mir auf die Finger, was heißt das für meinen Alltag und so weiter.
Ich habe bei dir im Brustball in deinem Newsletter ein schönes Wort gelernt, nämlich Koropka. Ich habe es wahrscheinlich auch schon falsch ausgesprochen.
Das stimmt, weil natürlich Russisch ein unbetontes O wird wie ein A gesprochen, also Karopka.
Karopka, okay. Ich glaube, ich werde bei dir nochmal in...
Schönes R hast du.
Ja, danke schön. Das ist meine fränkische Herkunft. Die kommt da manchmal dann doch noch durch. Ich glaube, ich werde bei dir nochmal in Klausur gehen müssen, bevor ich dann die russischen Nationalspieler irgendwann mal verwende, hier im Rasenfunk. Kannst du uns kurz da nochmal was zu sagen? Warum ist dieses Wort wichtig? Was bedeutet es denn eigentlich?
Karopka, das heißt sowas wie Schachtel, Behälter, Karton. Also wenn du was verpacken willst, dann brauchst du eine Karopka. Aber im Fußball-Zusammenhang sind das so Käfige, weißt du, so etwas, also so Bolzplätze. Natürlich nicht Feldgröße, sondern kleiner Käfig drum, damit der Ball möglichst keine Fensterscheiben trifft. Oder auch mal eine Wand. Boden durchaus unterschiedlich, nicht immer aus dem Material, was die Knie schont. Und das gehört hier zur Kultur. In vielen Innenhöfen gibt es das, wo dann eben Kinder rumbeuzen können. Das ist jetzt nicht immer Fußball, was da gespielt wird. Also zum Beispiel, eigentlich allen Ballsport. Manchmal siehst du, da hängen dann auch zusätzlich noch ein Basketball-Korb drin oder so. Oder zum Beispiel hier auf dem Innenhof, da wo ich wohne, das ist ein relativ internationaler Gebäudekomplex. Das heißt bei uns in der Karobka, ich merke immer, es wird Frühling, wenn die kleinen Jungs aus Indien da drin wieder Cricket spielen. Aber das ist halt so eine Institution und gerade auch in großen Städten, wo es dann eben doch ein Stück ist bis zur nächsten Grünanlage, wo du wirklich mal, als du nicht auf einer Wiese einen Ball rumschießen konntest, ist es eine Tradition und eine traditionelle Möglichkeit, schnell noch mal nach den Hausaufgaben vor dem Abendessen ein halbes Stündchen Ball hin und her zu schießen. Und da gab es einfach vor ein, zwei Wochen einen sehr schönen Artikel von einem russischen Journalisten, so eine Liebeserklärung an die Karobkas seiner Kindheit und voran er sich erinnert und was er da gelernt hat, auch über den Umgang mit Menschen und dass jeder mitspielen kann. Es war mehr als nur der konkrete Ort, auch eine Metapher und ich habe da auch mit meiner russischen Lehrerin die Woche noch mal darüber gesprochen, die sagt, also die ist pensionierte Dozentin und die sagt, seit ihrer Kindheit war das ein totaler Fixpunkt der Freizeitgestaltung für alle Kinder.
Ja, also es wird viel Fußball gespielt oder gebollt, gekickt, wie auch immer man es nennen will in diesem Land. Dass es mit dem Profi-Fußball dann irgendwie nichts hier hinhaut, das hat seine ganz eigenen Gründe, da werden wir glaube ich dann auch rund um das Turnier ja auch noch viel viel mehr über die russische Fußball-Nationalmannschaft erfahren. Jetzt ist die Auslosung am Freitag, sag doch mal kurz für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die diese Folge jetzt noch vor der WM-Auslosung sehen, wie kann man das denn durch deine Ohren und Augen mitverfolgen?
Also was ich vorhabe ist, ich glaube ich werde mir das im russischen Fernsehen mal anschauen und das live twitteren. Also ich heiße Edgar Scheib bei twitter, wenn das wen interessiert, also ich probiere das, ich habe keine Ahnung wie attraktiv das wird und ob sich die russische Fernsehberichterstattung da groß unterscheidet von dem, was man jetzt in Deutschland oder anderswo sehen kann, wahrscheinlich eher drum herum, so in der Vor- und Nachberichterstattung, denn das eigentliche Ereignis, die Stunde da mit der Erziehung, das ist garantiert auf die Minute durchgescriptet und für alle einheitlich. Aber ich versuche das mal, das könnte ja interessant sein und das ist ja auch direkt hier in der Nähe, also wenn ich in den Bus steige, ich bin in 10 Minuten da an dem staatlichen Kremlpalast, wo die Auslosung ist, das haben sie schon sehr bewusst hier ins Stadtzentrum gesetzt, damit auch das ganze Tamtam drum herum natürlich wieder zur Vorfreude beiträgt. Also gestern sah man da schon, da standen Übertragungswagen, da wurde Deko aufgebaut, ich bin da gestern Abend kurz vorbeigekommen.
Da kann man sich glaube ich darauf freuen, dann wissen wir auch, wer die Gegner der deutschen Nationalmannschaft sein werden und man kann so ein bisschen die groben... Ja, du ich bin auch froh, ich muss, ich bin schon die ganze Zeit am WM vorplanen für den Rasenfunk und für mich ist ja auch wichtig zu wissen, an welchen Spielen spielen die, wann muss ich gucken, mal den einen oder anderen Babysitter vielleicht noch organisieren, je nachdem wann wir, wann die deutsche Mannschaft nicht wir spielen. Da bin ich gespannt.
Werde ich die Gegner porträtieren?
Ja, ja gut, das ist im Rasenfunk ja sowieso maximal. Ich werde mich sowieso auf alle Mannschaften irgendwie vorbereiten in der WM-Vorschau. Da spare ich nicht an Vorbereitung. Deswegen, das ist nicht ganz so wild, weil ich da sowieso schon auf alle jetzt schon so ein bisschen mit drauf gucke. Und da hilft mir ja auch dein Newsletter zumindest so ein bisschen. Also mir gibt es echt einen tollen Einblick. Du machst das schon so lange seit... Im Juno hast du angefangen, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, ich habe die Ideen durch den Confed Cup entstanden, weil ich einfach gemerkt habe, hier findet was statt. Aber es kann ja jetzt nicht jeder Sportjournalist alle vier Jahre eine neue Sprache lernen. Das ist ja komplett legitim. Nur um dann über die WM in dem jeweils anderen Land zu berichten, habe ich gedacht, vielleicht ist das ganz nützlich. Und mir macht es natürlich total Spaß. Es ist eine super Vorbereitung auf die WM. Ich habe das mal auf so ein Jahr angelegt. Hab jetzt heute festgestellt, genau heute, das ist Folge 25. Also läuft.
Hast schon fast die Hälfte geschafft. Dann sag doch mal kurz den Hörern und Hörern, wir haben schon gelernt, bei Twitter heißt du EdKascheib, da kann man dir folgen. Das werde ich natürlich auch in den Show Notes nochmal verlinken. Und wo kann man denn den Newsletter abonnieren?
Ja, das habe ich heimtückisch so eingerichtet, dass das die gleiche URL ist, also kascheib.de. Da gibt es den in Blogform und da ist dann auch immer drunter so ein Anmeldeformular. Und da kommt dann auch exakt eine Mail pro Woche, also nämlich dieser Newsletter, nichts anderes, kein Spam, kein Gedöns.
Kann ich nur sehr empfehlen und dann kriegt man so, also bei mir hat es ehrlich gesagt geholfen, die Vorfreude ein bisschen anzuschüren. Auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10 mit 1 niedrigst und 10 völlige Begeisterung. Wie groß ist denn bei dir schon die Vorfreude aus Turnier? Bei mir ist es eine 3 und das ist aber schon viel, viel mehr als die 1, die ich noch neulich hatte. Das hängt aber halt auch damit zusammen, dass ich derzeit nur aus beruflicher Perspektive auf dieses Turnier gucke. Immer wenn ich bei dir lese, dann erfahre ich ganz, ganz viele Dinge, die ich so interessant finde. Und das Schöne ist ja, dass es da eigentlich gar nicht so sehr ums Sportliche geht, sondern eher um das Drumherum. Und das finde ich aktuell noch viel, viel spannender zu Sportliche, weil das sowieso... Also wir wüssten ja noch nicht mal, welche deutsche Mannschaft da antreten soll. Dann brauche ich mich jetzt auch noch nicht mit der Iranischen beschäftigen.
Das ist echt nett, dass du das sagst. Ich erröhte gerade, was du Gott sei Dank nicht siehst. Ich würde mich so bei einer 5 vielleicht einsortieren, eben halt auch, weil ich zum Beispiel dieses Vorglühen jetzt im Sommer schon hatte durch den Konfett Cup. Das war natürlich schon mal cool. So ein, zwei Stadien finde ich auch richtig großartig. Also das Stadion in Sochi, das Fischstadion, ist schon richtig toll, wenn du da in der Pause auf der Brüstung stehst und rausguckst aufs Wasser und es ist dunkel und es glitzert so ein bisschen. Also da verstehen schon Dinge im Bauch. Aber natürlich, klar, gerade wenn du hier lebst, ist natürlich auch, es ist überall Baustelle im Moment. Also gefühlt, im Sommer alle Straßen gefühlt einmal umgegraben, neu asfaltiert, was weiß ich. Das bremst natürlich, aber das machen wir ortsansässigen so, damit ihr es dann hinterher nett habt. Das ist schon in Ordnung. Und das geht natürlich auch noch weiter hoch. Aber man muss sich ja auch die Kraft noch ein bisschen einteilen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es ist noch lange hin, bis zur Weltmeisterschaft, aber mir hat es schon mal großen Spaß gemacht, vorauszublicken. Ich danke dir ganz, ganz sehr. Das war Katrin Scheib, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Danke dir, liebe Katrin. Ja, mir auch. Und dann sind wir doch mal gespannt, was bei der WM-Auslosen rauskommt. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ihr könnt den Rasenfunk unterstützen unter rasenfunk-slash-unterstützen, werdeteil des Rasenfunk-Supporters klappen. Und dann könnt ihr auch die WM folgen damit, schon mal vorfinanzieren. Danke euch dafür und bis zur nächsten Ausgabe im Rasenfunk.